bill murray tilda swinton adrian brody
owen wilson benicio del toro la alfombra
roja este festival de cannes se llenó
esta noche de estrellas de hollywood con
el estreno internacional y además en la
competencia oficial del festival de
cannes de the french dispatch la última
película del estadounidense wes anderson
quizás hasta ahora la película más
esperada de este festival nunca fue tan
difícil encontrar entradas para la
prensa y los críticos y hoy vimos muchos
festivaleros con letreros pidiendo una
invitación para alguna de las
proyecciones de esta película sino hoy
también pudimos ver en este festival de
cannes pero a través del vídeo llamada
adquirir serebrenik o el director ruso
recordamos que no puede salir de su país
porque allí fue condenado por
malversación de fondos públicos su
película la fiebre de petro fue muy bien
recibida por el público del festival de
cannes él lo pudo ver a través de esta
vídeo llamada cuenta la historia de un
hombre que confunde debido a una fiebre
el pasado el presente
- lineal que le toqué presentó aquí en
el 2018 pero con una puesta en escena
igual de teatral y con una excelente
banda sonora